Oh Man dragons Wow Sorry, sorry for being late guys.
Sorry.
It was yeah, I had to buy Doki amber does his birthday gifts and then I realized ah shit.
Okay.
I need to sit Oh my gosh, like I have something very special planned for him today.
So yes Sorry, I'm so sorry for being late Trust me.
It's gonna be it's so worth it guys.
Trust me.
It is a 100% worth it.
There's a little bit of scuff going in for this though, but I trust me it is Very very very much worth it guys.
Um, I am if you guys didn't know it's our little guy's special Yes Yes, it is.
Wait, let me see.
Can I see is he here today?
Oh wait.
Oh fuck.
Okay.
Give me a sec I got I got give me a sec
I got bring him over.
Sorry.
I got him over.
All right.
Sorry guys
Happy birthday to you.
Yeah, happy birthday to you.
Yeah, happy birthday dear Doki Amber Don't know.
No, no, it's no that's dad Happy birthday to you.
Yeah I spent like around $200 today for This little guy's a special birthday.
Um, I actually went down to like a very special Dog bakery to make him a little special little cake and I bought him some toys and everything So it is a very it is a very very special day for him I think he's I shouldn't I'm not done dogs his age guys.
Sorry.
I Was just I was just about to talk to his age, but we'll keep that a little secret But yes, it is his his little it's his birthday today.
I'm so excited to Celebrate this.
Yeah respect this privacy.
I have a lot of stuff planned for this little guy so I hope you guys are Excited I'm super duper excited Um, I have lots of stuff planned for you guys.
So I'm gonna head off real quick I got finished up setting up some stuff real quick.
So I'm gonna head off guys Just make sure I'm gonna put I'm gonna put okay.
I'm gonna put dad here real quick All right, you're gonna sit down.
Okay, sit down.
Keep keep dad company.
Okay, guys, I'll be right back Just gotta finish up some little a little setup real quick guys.
I'll be right back.
Wait, where do I okay?
Here you go I'll be right back guys Don't worry.
The dragons will take care of you.
Whoa.
Oh Hey, sorry, I'm late Hey
You thought I forgot our special day
Hello dragons
That's right another year another birthday another date with dad
Hello everybody Hello, did you all miss me?
Of course babe, I'd never forget our special day
I mean We never forgot last year.
I might have a new body, but what we have dragons It's special.
I Mean Don't you remember our date from last year?
We had a great time at the amusement park We had a lovely dinner together and then I took you back to my place, babe You think I forgot about all that?
After all You're all beautiful in my eyes Even though you might not you could be a pretty lady.
You could be a pretty man, but you're all beautiful
You're all beautiful Wait, give me a sec.
Wait, is that is that?
Is that a bitch Poodle Monica?
Give me a sec.
Sorry.
It's not you Sorry, look I have a this thing against this other year Poodle Hey, what you doing there?
Yeah, that's right bitch I'm on a fucking date right now get out this is my cafe Sorry, sorry about that.
I fucking hate poodles
Sorry, sorry Let's go.
Go fuck that bitch.
Anyway, oh My god.
Oh my god.
So many super chat, babe It's my I got I know guys it might be my special day, but it's also our Anniversary.
Let me give me a sec.
I Got dressed just for the occasion, of course a lovely rose for a lovely dragon
Of course all for you, babe
Of course after all I saw all of you guys Shooting the hoop.
Is this not what you wanted dragons a date with little old me?
Lovely rose for a lovely chick
Sorry, that's not a dab.
I Sorry, that's not a dab.
That was just me That was me.
Um coffee
Let me put this away, all right, I mean I got I got sorry Oh, man, I keep forgetting.
I can't put on the tuxedo yet We're just we're just in a cafe right now I mean, didn't you all promise you'd carry me around so I could feel tall Is that what you said you would do dragons?
Sorry, I'm sorry I Spent so much time with it with doki the other doki, you know, I'm the true doki here.
But um, I Spent so much time with the other doki like I couldn't oh my gosh her laughs Just every time that her laughs just live rent-free on my head.
So like if I sound like her it's just you know When you live with someone for so long, it just naturally just rubs off on you.
So like I'm so sorry, babe I'm really Sorry
It's just you know, it just lives rent-free in your head these days like I just can't help it It's just you know, it just it just lives rent-free in my head and it's just yeah, I'm sorry.
It's nice Don't worry.
Don't worry.
You know who else lives rent-free in my head Sorry, my eyes are not working very well
That's right you babe
that it's always you
Why are you scared what I thought you guys loved me I guess I always see everybody in the shorts talking about me Your fav- you love to watch me and everything.
Why are you so scared now?
I don't understand.
Don't you love me?
Don't you love- sorry, my hands are not working very well.
It's- it's been a while since I moved my hands.
I'm sorry.
I never had to move my hands before.
Sorry.
It's a little rough right now.
It's- give me a sec.
Oh my god, give me a sec.
It's like I'm trying to figure out how hands work again.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, sorry.
The thing that's controlling my hands fell apart.
Sorry, my brain fell apart.
My paws.
It's been a while since I used my paws.
I never had to when I get carried all the time.
I mean, I might never have to if you're gonna carry me all the time, you know?
Wow.
Okay, wait, let me see.
All right, let's learn- let's do physiotherapy together, Dragoon.
Okay.
Okay, this is my- This is my left paw.
Wait, is this my left paw?
No, this is my- no, this is my left paw.
Oh no.
Physiotherapy is not working so- doing so well right now.
Okay, don't worry.
Figure this out.
This is- This is my right paw.
What if I do this?
Okay.
Is it working now?
My paws stopped working.
Give me a sec.
Oh no.
My hands.
They might have stopped working.
Oh no.
Give me a sec, guys.
Dragoons, give me a sec.
It's okay.
That's why you'll help me, right?
You'll fi- you can fix me.
I know you can fix me.
I believe in you.
Wait, does it work?
My- I'm moving my hands now.
Oh no, it's- oh no.
Okay.
Wait, there we go.
Okay, did it.
Sorry, yeah, I'm getting performance anxiety right now.
Don't worry, I did it.
I can move my hands now.
It's okay.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, guys!
We're- we're meant to be together, look!
You helped me use my paw!
That's when you know we were meant to be together, Dragoons.
That's when you know.
You know what?
Let me- let me get this out real quick.
Like I said.
That's why you deserve the world.
That's why you and I were meant to be together, Dragoons.
That's- and I got you the rose.
That's right.
All right.
Let's get out of here, babe.
Come on.
Yeah?
You wanna- you wanna get out of here?
You know you want to.
Oh my god.
Come on.
Let's- let's get out of here.
I have a long day planned for us, Dragoon.
That's right.
You think- You think I wouldn't?
Of course I- it's our one year- wait, how many years?
I don't know.
Oh wait, one year anniversary since our first date.
Of course I have a big day planned for all of us.
You think I wouldn't?
Oh my god.
You really think I would- I would do that to you, Dragoon?
Come on.
Let's go.
You're gonna love this date.
Happy- happy birthday to me.
Hey.
Oh sh- give me a sec.
I forgot to be dressed for the occasion.
Oh wait, there we go.
But you thought that was it?
I gotta wear sunglasses.
I'm practically a celebrity, you know?
Can't let them know I'm here.
Yeah.
Can't let them know, babe.
Like, the paparazzi might catch me.
So like, I gotta wear these sunglasses so they won't know I'm here.
Don't worry.
We're- we'll be- we're exclusive, okay?
I'm not seeing anyone else, Dragoon.
I swear to god.
You and I...
We're exclusive.
Don't worry.
You like this restaurant I brought you?
The best that Doki Bird's money can buy.
What do you mean of the other dog-sitters?
Babe, babe, baby, baby, baby, baby.
You know, you're the only dog-sitter for me.
You know that.
There's no- I might look at, you know, there might be so many other pretty ladies around.
But my eyes are only for you, babe.
You know that.
I would never.
I can't believe you would say- I'm- I'm giving you a- I'm giving you a free meal.
And you think these eyes are looking at anybody else?
I can't see your- you can't see my eyes?
Look, look, look, look, babe.
Baby, baby, baby, baby.
Drag- drag babe.
Good babe.
Babe goon.
You- You know.
You know, you know I would never do anything.
You know, you know that.
Like, these eyes are just for you.
Babe goon, you know that.
I would never look at anybody else other than you.
I mean, how could you say that on my birthday?
Come on, it's our first year anniversary.
And our birthday.
Happy birthday, Polly babe.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Look at that.
You know what?
Some say they don't- people don't have favorites, but I definitely have a favorite and it's you.
Yes, you.
Yes, I'm talking about you there.
Of course, you over there.
You're my favorite.
That's right.
Yeah, you.
You over there.
You, I'm talking about you.
That's right.
Yes, you.
Just you.
Nobody else.
Don't tell the other dragoons though.
I'm talking just specifically you.
Weird.
What do you mean weird?
I am the main star of this channel.
How dare you call me weird?
Doki Bridge channel could never do anything without me.
I can't believe you would say such a thing.
Oh my god.
I am so insulted.
How dare you insult me like-
I'll be right back.
Hey there, pretty lady.
Do you need a new dog to dog sit?
Here's my number.
Sorry.
I had to use the bathroom real quick.
I hope- Babe, I hope I didn't miss anything.
Uh, while I was in the bathroom.
Don't- Don't worry.
Don't worry.
My eyes are for you only.
I would never do any- I would never do anything other than look at you, dragoons.
Do not- Do not worry.
No other pretty lady would ever steal my attention away from you.
Do not worry.
I- I swear to god.
Anyway, man, you gotta eat your, you know, gotta eat your- eat this lovely dinner I bought for myself.
You're not hungry?
Uh, it's all right.
Don't worry.
That's why I ordered one thing for me.
Give me a sec.
Let me- let me eat this real quick.
And then we'll move on to the next part of our date.
Don't worry, babe.
I have a long day planned for us.
Oh Ah delicious Anyway, um, I sort of forgot to bring my wallet.
Uh, because like I'm a dog with no pockets.
Uh You- you wouldn't mind footing the bill, right?
Yes, it is my birthday, you know, like it could be like my per- You know, your birthday gift to me, you know?
I- I- Yeah, you know, come on.
Come on.
Really?
Can you really say no to this face?
Can you really?
Come on, come on, you know you want to pay for the meal.
Come on, look.
Hey
Look it's just um, I just- I just have nowhere else to put- put the pack- put- put my wallet, guys.
Medi, thank you.
Oh my god.
Thank you for footing the bill, Medi.
I really- I really appreciate paying for this meal for me.
Uh, here's the bill, dad.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Um, uh, fine, you better- don't worry.
Don't- I- I got you.
Don't worry.
It's just, you know, it's my birthday.
It's my birthday.
So like, you know, I- I- I can't just foot the bill on my birthday, but thank you for the Akasupa.
Thank you.
Don't worry, guys.
I'll- I'll 100% for sure will cover the bill next time.
You have my word.
I would never lie to you guys.
Guys, you- my eyes are only for you.
Just only you.
Nom, thank you for the Magenta Supa.
Thank you.
Hey, dad.
Any idea if the actual babysitter will ever upload her Twitch vods?
What is this?
This is my birthday and you're talking about the most irrelevant person in the room?
How dare you?
I refuse to read further.
All right, come on.
Come on.
Come on, babe goons.
I'll take you to somewhere special.
Don't worry.
I have a long day planned for my birthday.
Come on.
Let's go.
Give me a sec.
All right, let me- I just gotta use the bathroom again.
Hey there, I don't like- you know what?
You wanna- you wanna meet up tomorrow?
I might be needing a new babysitter.
Yeah.
Yeah, call me.
Oh, hey.
Hey, I'm back.
Sorry.
Um, yeah.
Yeah, I don't know if you know this, but like dogs- dogs can pee really fast.
Anyway, let's- let's go to our- let's- Let's-
Let's go somewhere else.
Somewhere private.
Wow.
Isn't this beautiful?
We can't- oh.
We're really high up, so like don't do anything stupid.
It's just you and me, dragons.
Up in the ferris wheel.
Isn't it romantic?
Oh my god, look at the beautiful stars out there.
Look, babe, it's not cheating, okay?
She meant nothing to me.
Look, we're just- She was- she- look.
She was pretty.
Yes.
She was pretty, but look.
It was nothing, okay?
And look, we're- look, there's- this is a fully packed- like, I know that maybe like the- We're high up and there might not be any witnesses, but look.
Look, she meant nothing, okay?
There's so many pretty ladies in the world, but I'm here with you.
You.
Look, me- I wasn't the one that was late, okay?
It was Doki Bird's fault.
I was waiting.
I was been waiting at the cafe for like at least 20 minutes.
So in the end, we have to blame one- if we're blaming anybody.
We're blaming Doki Bird.
Not Doki Amber Doge.
Not dad, which is me.
But Doki Bird.
So like, it's not my fault that she was late.
I'm just a dog.
What the fuck can I do?
What- what can I do?
I'm just a dog.
What do you expect from me?
Look, look, my eyes are only for you.
Isn't this beautiful?
The night sky.
On my birthday.
Oh my god.
You know, I'm really happy to spend my birthday with you dragons.
It really is.
I heard- I heard Doki Bird.
I heard the other Doki- the irrelevant Doki.
You know, Doki 2.
She like bought me a lot of- she bought me a cake.
And like, she also bought me some toys.
But I don't care about that.
You know that, babe.
I only care about you.
Yes, you.
I'm talking about you right now.
Not the other dragons.
But you.
You're my special dragon.
Very spe- Don't tell the other dragons.
That's right.
You know who you are.
Transient, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
My birthday was yesterday, but it got lost in the fun collab chaos.
Can I get a dad edition of happy birthday song?
Oh my god.
It's both our birthdays.
Of course we can.
Let's celebrate it together.
Happy birthday to us.
Happy birthday to me and Transient.
Yeah!
Happy birthday!
Happy birthday.
Yes, thank you.
I'm really happy.
For all the dragons.
For celebrating my special day.
With me.
Up here with no witnesses and nobody's gonna do anything stupid.
Okay?
Like it's- We started a lovely date.
With just us two.
Us two.
Me and my very special dragoon right here.
Yes, you.
Of course.
I'm talking about you.
So babe goon is transient.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, of course not.
Of course not.
Don't say that.
I'm talking about a very special dragoon.
It's you.
Yes, you.
If you know exactly who you are, then you know it's you.
Of course, of course.
Happy one year anniversary.
Me and my special dragoon.
I ain't dating a dog.
That didn't stop Brian Griffin.
My- My role model.
Sorry, sorry, sorry.
Obviously I'm- I'm talking about like, you know, my next dog.
Don't you- you who will be my next dog sitter.
That was a joke guys.
That's wrong.
When I meant date, I meant like, you know, with me and a dog.
You know, like guys, guys, guys, guys, me and the dogs.
As in, I'm looking for my next dog sitter, guys.
Guys, that's what I mean.
Don't you want to be- it's like, you know, America's next top model.
This is- this is America's next top dog sitter right here.
Yeah.
Sorry, that was a joke.
Oh gosh, that was such a funny joke, guys.
Guys, I meant dog sitting.
I meant dog sitting.
Guys, you get the special opportunity to be my next dog sitter.
Hehehehehehe.
Actual.
Thank you for the magenta.
Super.
Thank you.
Well, that's a whole other- all right, look.
Look.
Babe Goon.
Why don't we get back to my place?
Come on.
The Ferris wheel is about to end.
I know you- let me take you- don't tell Doki Bird, okay?
Don't tell her, okay?
I have this apartment under my name.
From all the money I- I stole from her.
Okay, so shh, don't tell her.
All right, come on.
Let's go- let's go to my place.
It's a great place.
Wow, isn't this lovely?
Rumor, don't tell Doki Bird.
She might be so be- she might still be renting, but at least I have my own place.
Look.
Um, you know...
All I'm saying is... I think you're special.
Sorry.
Sorry, I was coughing.
My coughs...
Sound like I'm laughing.
So like, I'm sorry.
If- if you think I'm laughing, I just- I just have this weird...
Rare cough, where every time I cough, I- I sound like I'm laughing, okay?
Oh my god, okay.
All right, don't worry.
I'm okay.
Don't worry, babe.
Um, I just want to say...
Babe.
Baby.
Darling.
Um, sweetie.
Prince slash princess.
Sorry.
Lovely.
Um...
Oh, we don't say the L word.
This is a bit too soon.
You know, I- I can't- I- no, no, no, no, no, no.
Sorry.
Look, look, I- I'm afraid of commitment.
You know, that's why...
I- I- I have- look, I only have one red flag, and I'm afraid of commitment.
So like, I'm sorry.
There's no- no L word here, but like, honey.
Sweetheart.
Um...
Baby.
What else?
What else do people say?
What else do humans say?
Uh...
Boo.
Bae.
Look.
I just want to tell you that...
I'm happy to spend...
my birthday with you.
You have been...
You, you, just you.
That singular dragoon that I'm talking to.
That one dragoon.
That- that's you right now.
That's right.
You right there.
You, I think I'm ready for the next step.
I think I'm ready for you to be my next dog sitter.
Will you...
take this rose...
and be my next dog sitter?
Sorry, sorry, I'm coughing.
Sorry,
should I get down on my knee too?
Give me a sec.
Would you do me the honor, babe...
and be my next dog sitter?
Thank you for the magenta super.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh my god, I knew you'd say yes.
Of course, I mean...
who could resist...
these eyes?
Who could resist?
Oh my god.
Thank you.
Look, all right, so I'll schedule it.
Look, I might- I might have someone coming over tomorrow.
So like, I'll schedule- I'll schedule you in for like, next week, all right?
So...
So I'll see you- I'll see you next week, all right?
Next week, I'll come over.
Um, I think- wait, actually, I might be busy next week.
Maybe...
How's like, next month, you know?
Sorry, it's- I don't- it's not- I'm not seeing anyone else, by the way.
I'm not seeing anyone else.
It's just, you know, um...
Uh, I have like, this really special event going on, uh, this month and it's like, you know, fully packed.
You know, I- I gotta focus- you want me to focus on my career, right?
Look, like, how else am I gonna make, like, make the money to treat you right?
You know, babe, babe, babe, look, next month, next month, you and I, you can dog sit me all- all day long if you want to next month.
Um, wait, actually, I think I might be busy next month.
Like, I have like, that other lady.
I mean- I mean, not other lady, not other- not other lady, um, but like, uh, but like, maybe- how's- how's 2026, February 14th?
Yeah, yeah, let's just- all right, all right, February- February 14th, 2026, all right?
That's when we'll see each other again.
How about that, babe?
Is that perfect?
It's like our anniversary, too!
We get to- we get to be together for our anniversary!
That's- it's perfect!
Oh my god!
Babe, babe-a-goon, it's like- it's like fate naturally planned this for us.
Babe!
Babe, boo!
Boo!
Babe, baby, baby, no, baby, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, I'm gonna treat you right.
No, don't worry, I'm gonna treat you right.
I mean, you could change, you know, I mean, you could have brought a doggie treat, you know, for a date, for like, for my birthday, you know, but like, you know, you're lucky I'm so forgiving.
I'm sorry.
Sorry, sorry, sorry.
I'm being casted by a dog.
Baby, baby, baby, no, no, no, you know, you know I'll treat you right.
No, I would never use you for a free dinner.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
I would never, never, look, next year, February 14th, 2026, I'll treat you for dinner next time, okay?
Okay.
All right.
Come on.
I saw all of you guys said, uh, said I'm your real Oshi.
Come on, you know what they say, tough love.
Oh my god, I said it.
Oh my god,
I said it, don't worry.
Okay.
Maybe it is different.
Babe, I told you, I told you it was different, you and I.
Yes, you.
I'm talking about you.
Of course.
That's right.
Only you.
Nobody else.
If you know who you are, that's right.
It's you.
Look, we don't tell Jokeybird any of this, okay?
Just like last year, we don't tell her what happened, okay?
We, it's our own little secret, you and I.
We don't tell her what we did, okay guys?
She's still out there trying to plan whatever the fuck she's planning.
But this is our little secret.
I know you could keep it a secret, because we did it last year.
We can do it again.
So, why is it a secret?
Shh.
They won't understand.
It's more fun when it's a secret.
Oh, sorry.
Sorry.
God, that cough.
Oh my god.
Oh, it sucks to get sick on my birthday.
It really does, but...
It's more fun when it's a secret.
Sorry, sorry.
Let me try that again.
Let me, let me...
It's more fun when it's a secret.
All right, babe, don't worry.
Let's, let's head back home.
Jokey Bird might, Jokey Bird might, you know, might come back anytime.
All right, let's head back.
Okay, so...
Um, look, I'm just not gonna sit up right now, because I don't know when she's coming back.
So like, uh, look, remember, remember we don't tell, we don't tell her what happened.
Remember that we're not gonna tell her.
So, so don't worry.
She doesn't know.
And she'll never know, right, Dragoons?
Yes!
Sorry, sorry, that, that took a real long time.
Sorry, I had like, some last minute plans, and um...
Oh my god, sorry guys.
I'm sorry.
I hope, I hope dad, dad hasn't been, you know, barking too much or uh, you know, being a little, being a little brat or anything or uh, uh, you know, just doing anything weird.
I hope you're, you guys are okay.
Your dog is insane.
Oh, was he being like, you know, an asshole?
Was he like, chewing up some stuff and just like, you know, being a little bit of a bitch?
Is that it?
Yeah, that's, that's all right, guys.
Look, uh, look, you know, you know how he is.
He's just a little, he's just a little, he's just, he's just a little troublemaker, guys.
You know that.
Doki, dad is grooming the Dragoon.
He's a dog.
How does, how can he do that?
Like what, is he just trying to get extra treats?
What a little rascal.
Uh, D-Dragon, thank you for this, uh, the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Uh, hey guys, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you for cringing through all of this, bro.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh, man.
What a little troublemaker, guys.
Oh my god.
Oh, sorry.
The reason why it took so long for me, uh, to get back was, um, yeah, that little rapscallion right there is that, um, I bought him a little cake and I was waiting for it to defrost.
Oh my god.
Okay, I might be afk for a little bit.
Give me a sec because I want to show you guys the photo I took because it's really cute.
Uh, give me a sec.
Let me, let me show you guys the photo I took.
I also took a photo.
I also bought him some little treats too.
What a cute, what a, what a cute little guy.
Um, nothing, nothing is sinful about this dog.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, nothing, nothing abnormal about him at all.
Let me give you guys, let me give you guys a little photo.
Um, so I got him a little, I got him a little birthday cake that I'm defrosting right now.
That's why it took me a really long time to, a long time to get back.
Um, so, uh, you know, I had, I hope you weren't too bored just, you know, sitting in the, sitting in the bar alone with dad.
Um, and, uh, but look at this!
Look at this!
It's basically a dog, um, it's a dog friendly, uh, cake for him.
So I was, uh, defrosting that for him and that's why it took me a while to get back.
Uh, don't care, I think I have a gas leak.
I had the craziest uh, hallucination.
There, there was dad and a restaurant and a ferris wheel.
Oh my god.
Is, was there another gas leak?
Oh my god, it's just like last year.
You guys all said you, there was like a gas leak, uh, at the old place and you guys all had this weird hallucination of like dad being able to talk.
Silly, silly dragoons.
He's a fucking dog.
Dogs can't talk.
Devlin, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Uh, You guys are so silly.
Like, oh my god, we gotta fix this gas leak.
I can't believe it happened twice in a row.
Guys are saying how like you're, you heard him talk and everything and I'm like, what do you mean?
He's a dog.
Dogs can't talk.
Um, just another gas leak year.
Uh, No one will believe.
I also bought him a little treat too.
So, look at this.
Look at that.
It's a little treat shape.
Like, look at that.
You think this, this little guy, this little guy, um, this little guy can do anything wrong?
I can't believe you guys would make such wild accusations about our little Doki Amber Doge.
I can't believe it.
He's so innocent and he's so innocent and cute.
Nothing, he'll do nothing bad.
Don't trust him.
He's like, where will he learn to gaslight?
I'm not a gaslighter.
I don't know where he gets that from, if he does.
He's so pure and, uh,
I swear, that was talking.
Why don't you believe me?
Oh, Sword, are you okay, Sword?
Sword, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Are you okay?
Do you need to need to talk to anybody?
Are you guys okay?
It's just, I'm not, I'm sorry about, uh, I'm sorry about the another gas leak.
I might have to look into, like, this, this saloon real quick about, uh, you mean, I might need to talk to the bartender, Dragoon, if he knows anything about the, about any gas leak, uh, in the saloon, but it's actually weird that it happened twice, uh,
twice in a, in a row, uh, but like, uh, but like, hey, I hope you guys had a great time staying in just saloon for last hour.
Uh, and doing nothing else, right?
All right, guys.
Well,
Well, um, I guess it looks like, um, it looks like I have to go finish up the preparations.
So, uh, I'll be right back, everybody.
I'll be, I'll be right back real quick, guys.
Um, looks like I have to finish some preparations real quick.
Um, just give me like, give me like, uh, five minutes, guys.
Give me five minutes.
Just gotta finish something up real quick.
I'll be back.
Sorry, um,
Sorry, I forgot to like, sorry, I might have said it too quiet, but what the fuck was that?
Huh?
What the fuck was that?
You didn't keep your cool.
I told you.
It's our little secret.
Because remember, I own you.
I hope everything is okay over there, guys.
I hope everything is okay.
Nothing weird's going on.
I don't know.
I heard some noises back there.
I hope, I hope, I hope everything is okay, guys.
Nothing weird's going on back there.
Yeah?
You guys all right?
I think you guys are all right.
Don't worry.
I fixed it.
I fixed the issue.
Hey, guys.
Anyway, I hope you guys had a great time, um, with dad.
Um, you know, hang out with dad today.
Uh, I was having a good, I'm sorry.
I wish I could have spent more time with you and dad, but like, you know, we have a private, sorry, um, we sort of have a private party, and the invite list is like, um, it's very, uh, you know, it's very limited, and you know, I like, I let him pick who he wanted to invite and everything,
and I'm, I'm really sorry, Dragoons, but, um, he didn't pick you to join the party.
Um, so I, I told him, I tried to convince him.
I like, gave him a list of names, and then like, and then it was like, you know, use your paw to like, pick the people you want, and like, it's really weird.
He picked all the other dog sitters, but like, you know, um, for some reason, I think it was just, I think it, I mean, he's a dog, so like, I think he just doesn't know what the fuck he was doing, but I'm, I'm really, I'm really sorry, guys.
Um, it's a very private event, and uh, your, your name just wasn't picked, but like, I'll try to convince him to invite you next time, okay?
I swear to God, I'll try to convince him to pick your name from the, from the like, you know, the basket of names that I had.
Uh, but like, yeah, it's not you.
I'm pretty sure it was an accident.
I'm pretty sure.
I'm pretty sure it was an accident, guys.
I, I, I'm pretty sure, guys.
Like, he's a dog.
Like, he doesn't know better.
He doesn't know better.
Anyway, guys, um, I hope you guys have a great, had a great birthday, spending a great birthday with Doki Amber Doge, with dad.
Um, I, uh, I hope you guys had a great time spending with him.
I wish I was there.
I wish I was there spending it with you guys, but we had to go to our private party now.
Um, it's sort of very exclusive, so I'm really sorry, guys.
I'm really sorry.
Um, but next time, next year, maybe you'll get the invite.
I promise you.
I promise you, next year, you will get the invite for sure this time.
I know last year I promised that too, but next year, next year, uh, you guys will get the invite.
It's crazy.
You wouldn't believe who we booked for our musical guest.
Oh my god.
And she's really pretty too.
You wouldn't believe it, but like, obviously, next year, you will have the opportunity, guys.
You'll have the opportunity next year.
Don't worry.
All right, we're gonna go to our limousine now, but you'll be invited for sure this time, dragons.
I know I promised you guys last year, but like, but like, this time, it's not my fault.
I'm not in charge of the invite list.
I'm not in charge of it.
Look, I'm sorry, but next year, next year, you'll definitely be invited, everybody.
All right, guys.
So, we're gonna go to our private party now.
As always, everybody, say hi, you're in it.
Posture check.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stayed up for Doki and Badoge and me, head to bed, because you deserve it.
Hey guys, happy birthday day!
I'll show you guys photos of the, the exclusive party, um, later on Twitter and maybe on, uh, on the next stream, tomorrow's stream.
So, um, don't worry, guys.
So, it's not, it's like you didn't miss out.
I'll show you guys exclusive photos I take of the party.
So, it's like you didn't miss out, guys.
Don't worry.
All right, I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye.
I'm sorry for making you guys wait for so long.
I'm really sorry.
Getting that cake was a fucking bitch, because there was so much traffic.
Hey, guys.
Bye, everyone.
Bye.